ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนทุกๆคนนะครับมาเจอ
กับอ่าน้องอาร์ตี้ครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู
พี่เอ๋ที่ไหนคะโอเคที่ช่องคอมพรีเฮน
เซเบิลไทยนับวันนี้นะโอเค
แล้ววันนี้ที่เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะวันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้ที่เรามาทักทายกันวันนี้
อ่านะกลัวตี้หาปฏิทินน่าจะเธอแล้วครับ
ปฏิทินวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันจันทร์ครับวัน
จันทร์ไปหาใช่ครับหัวนั่นเสื้อสีเหลืองหอ
วันจันทร์สีเหลืองหรอโอเควันจันทร์สี
เหลืองวันจันทร์นี้วันจันทร์ครับวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่ 4  27
ครับ
ที่ 27  5  8 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับเดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมครับๆเดือน
ธันวาคม k  5 เดือนธันวาคม
ปีพตตพ.ศ.นั้น
ปีพต
2564 ครับ
ใช่ครับ 2560
164 ให้เขาปีคศเท่าไหร่ค่ะปีพศ.
2020  11 ครับ 555  2000
2021 นะคะให้ครับวันนี้เรามาเจอกันแล้ว
เวลาตอนนี้ก็ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่าตอนนี้อะ
แต่ 10:00 น
10:00 น 20 นาทีครับ
20 นาทีน่าใช้ครับสิบยี่สิบนาที
ยังวันนี้วันนี้ครูอันตี้ตอนนี้ครู Arty
มีอะไรอ่ะ
วันนี้นักเรียนต้องหนึ่งเป็นได้เฮ้ยอ่า
วันนี้ควรตี้มีเรื่องเกี่ยวกับอ่าเอ่องาน
งานทำงานมีงานอะไรบ้างครับอ่า
ครู Arty อ่ะตอนนี้กำลังพูดพูดครับเหี๊ย
ทำงานเนี่ย
ๆกลัวพี่เป็นครูครูพูดว่าอาชีพหมอ
อาชีพครูใช่ครับ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็อ่านจะรีบครูน่ารักหาชิดค่ะ
ครับนักเรียนอาชีพอะไรไม่รู้
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนนะไปดูแล้วก็ฟังอ่ะมีอาชีพ
อะไร
นักเรียนก็พิมพ์พิมพ์นักเรียนอ่าชีพอร่อย
ไหมๆในธรรมครู Arty มีอาชีพอะไรให้นัก
เรียนดูคะ 5 มีอาชีพที่ 1 ครับอาชีพที่ 1
เป็นอะไรคะอ่ะอาชีพ
อาชีพ
ครับหน้าชีพตำรวจ
ตำรวจไทยใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับตำรวจของประเทศ
ไทยมีใส่ชุดสีสี 4 คนไทยพูดสีกากี้สีกากี
ใช้ขาวๆมีสีกากีนะคะก็เป็นตำรวจนะฮะโห
ตำรวจ
ครับตำรวจไม่สวัสดีตำรวจไม่สวัสดีคนฉัน
ที่ปิดขวดอี้ครูพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ตำรวจไม่สวัสดีตำรวจอ่ะทำอะไรอ่าตำรวจทำ
แบบนี้ครับ 5 สวัสดีครับแบบนี้อ่ะครับ
ไม่มือแล้วก็อ้าใช่ครับใช้มือข้างเดียว
ขวาข้างเดียวอ่าสวัสดีใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
อันนี้ตำรวจสวัสดีนะคะเขาและไม่ใช่จะไม่
ไม่ใช่ทรายนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้ทำไม่ใช่
สวัสดีใช้ขาวนะคะ
ตำรวจนะคะมีโหมดอะไรครับใส่หมวกอ่ะค่ะ
แล้วตำรวจทำงานที่ไหนคะอ่ะตีตำรวจทำงาน
ที่
สถานีตำรวจครับนี้สถานี
ตำรวจหน้ามีตำรวจรถตำรวจด้วยมีก็เป็นรถ
ของตำรวจตำรวจขับรถด้วยนะครับรถตำรวจหน้า
ครับตำรวจทำงานสถานีตำรวจครู Arty กับครู
เอ๋ทำงานที่บ้านฮ่าๆๆครับปวดที่ไม่ทำงาน
ที่สถานีตำรวจไม่มาเห็นตำรวจทำที่สถานี
ตำรวจหน้า
ตำรวจทำงานสถานีตำรวจไปครับ
อาชีพ
มีอาชีพต่อให้มีอาชีพอีกครับมีอาชีพต่อไป
อาชีพที่ 2 ครับอ่ามีแฟนที่อาชีพอะไรคะ
อ่ะคิดว่าอาชีพอะไรครับแม่แบบนี้เอง
อาชีพอะไรครับอาชีพ
ซื้อเสื้อ
40 สีขาวได้เสื้อสีขาวนะครับมีมีหู
สายฟังอ่าใช่ครับหูฟังให้ครับ
รู้อ่ะอ๋ออ๋อค่ะอ่าถูกต้องครับอาชีพบ่อ
หมอใช่ครับ
เน้นหมอนะครับแกหมอครับอ่ะแล้วหมอหมอทำ
งานที่ไหนพี่เอกแล้วหมอทำงานที่ไหนครับ
หมอทำงานสถานีตำรวจได้มั้ยเอ่อหมอไม่ไป
สถานีตำรวจครับอ่าตำรวจให้ทุกภาพที่สถานี
รูปภาพนี้หมอไม่ไปไม่ไปครับมีตำรวจงานที่
สถานีตำรวจไอ้ครับไม่ทำนะหมอทำงานที่โรง
พยาบาล
ใช่ครับเป็นหมอต้องทำงานที่โรงพยาบาลครับ
มีอาที่โรงพยาบาลพยาบาลชายอาหารมีรถเนาะ 5
มีรถพยาบาลใช้ครับ
มีรถพยาบาลแต่คุณหมอคุณหมอไม่นั่งรถเสี่ย
บ่หันอ๋อคุณหมอทำงานข้างในอยู่ในโรง
พยาบาลใต้ครับในโรงพยาบาลอ่ะตอนนี้ก็มี
อาชีพตำรวจใช้ครับมีตำรวจมีอาชีพหมอใช่
ครับ
มี 3 ไหมคะอามีครับมีสามด้วยอาทิตย์ที่ 3
เป็นอ่าอาชีพนี่นี้เขากำลังทำอะไรครับ
กำลังทำอะไรครับตัดผมอาร์กำลังตัดผม
ขอโทษตัดผมผู้ชายหากไม่ค่อยขึ้นใครใช้
กรรไกรนิดหน่อยแต่ว่าใช้ปัตตาเลี่ยนหน้า
ใช้ปัตตาเลี่ยนอันนี้อาแล้วก็หวี
ในครับอาอัด 6 ตัดผมเรียกอาชีพช่างตัดผม
ขอเรียกว่าอาชีพช่างตัดผมใช่ครับเป็นช่าง
ตัดผมหาอะไรนะพูดอีกข้างนึงอ้ะอาชีพช่าง
ตัดผมครับ
โอเคค่ะตัดหงส์
ช่างตัดผมขับ
ครูเอ็ดดี้ครับแล้วช่างตัดผมทำงานที่ไหน
คะอ้าช่างตัดผมทำงาน 4 สถานีตำรวจไม่ใช่
โรงพยาบาลไม่ใช่หน้าช่างตัดผมทำงานที่นี่
ครับที่นี่นี่
เรียกว่าอะไรค่ะเรียกว่าร้านตัดผม
ร้านตัดผมชายครับเป็นร้านตัดผมอ่านี่ครับ
พี่ครับอาชีพช่างตัดผมทำงานที่ร้านตัดผม
ชายขับ
อาหารตามอาชีพแล้วเนาะอาชีพตำรวจอาชีพหมอ
อาชีพช่างตัดผมอาชีพที่ 4 ไหมคะถ้ามีครับ
อาชีพที่ 4 เป็นอาชีพนี่ครับ R
อะไรสีสี
แดง
ใส่ครับใส่หมวกก็สีแดงไซส์ครับน้าชุดสี
แดงนี้แทนอาอ้านี้เป็นสายยางฉายาหายางามิ
น้ำออกมาจากสายยางมีนา
กูอาร์จีอาทิตย์นี้เรียกว่าอาชีพอะไรคะ
อาชีพนี้เป็นนะดับเพลิง
ชายเราเป็นยังไงเธอเริงก็คือเออเป็น
เดี๋ยวนักควรตี้เพลิงต้องเป็นสีแดงเนื้อ
เพลิงก็คือไปนะครับอ่าเวลามีไฟล์ไม่ขอพี่
มีบ้านแล้วก็มีไฟไม่ใช่ครับก็ช่างแต่นัด
ดับเพลิงก็จะฉีดน้ำลงไปนี้ใช้สายอ่างจุด
ไฟให้ไม่มี
เวลาบ้านเดี๋ยวนะมีบ้านใช่ไหมอ่ามีป้าน
บ้านไปไม่
บ้านไปไม่นักแต่เพลินก็ฉีดน้ำฉีดเขาอาสนะ
บัญชีไฟช็อตเออให้เขาไฟไม่ไหม้นักดับ
เพลิงก็มาขี่หน้า
แมคโครดับเพลิงฉีดน้ำดับเพลิงใช่ครับ
มีน้ำอ้าน้ำดับตายครับดับเลย
ครับนัดดับเพลิงทำงานที่ไหนอ่ะดับเพลิง
เข้างานที่ที่ที่มีเขาที่เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เรียกว่าสถานีดับเลิงหาสถานีดับเพลิงเลย
ครับฮักบนมีข้างบน 5 เป็นรูปข้างบนไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ไฟไหม้นะไม่ใช่เป็นรูปเป็นรูปสถานี
ดับเพลิงใช่ครับฉันหานี่ดับเพลิงก็จะมี
เปิดเว็บหน้านี่รถดับเพลิงอยู่ตรงนี้นะ
ครับเออโอเคดับเพลิงอ่าหาผมขอรับและแบบ
เทอมจะมีเสียงไหมอ้ามีเสียงครับมีเสียง
งาน 5 เสียงยาวๆ volt ๆ
เป็นเสียงรถดับเลิงโอเคโอเคเออ
กี่อาชีพอาชีพเสียที่มีตำรวจมีหมอ
3-5 มีช่างตัดผม 4 เหมาะนะดับเพลิงโอเค
ตอนนี้มี 4 อาชีพนะคะผมอาชีพ 5 ไหมคะมี
ครับอาชีพที่ 5 ครับอาชีพที่ 5 แป้งเป็น
ในครับหานี้เขาอาทิโว่ชุดสีกางกี้เมือง
ตำรวจมาย
ถ้าไปแถวเห
เฮ้ยเฮ้ยหามีกระดานท้ายครับเป็นกระดานเอา
ไว้
แล้วก็ถือไม้มีลายชนิดดินสอน่ะ
อะไรคะอ้าอาชีพโลโก้อาชีพครูครับงานเป็น
ครูในครับ
อาชีพ on  1  +  1  =  2 ใช่ครับ
ครู
ครับครู Arty ก็อาชีพครูเป็นครูเป็นอาชีพ
ครูทรายครับ
ครูอาร์ทตี้แล้วอาชีพครูทำงานที่ไหนคะอ้า
อาชีพครูทำงานที่
โรงเรียนครับเพราะโรงเรียนที่โรงเรียน
คะ
อันนี้เป็นครูสำหรับเด็กเด็กหาใช้ครับครู
สำหรับเด็กๆต้องไปทำงานที่โรงเรียนครู
Arty ครูเอะครูเอ๋ไม่ใช่เด็กๆก็อายุ 3
ปี 4 ปีใช่ครับ 6 ปี 7 ปี 8 ปี 9 ปี 10
ปีอายุเท่าไหร่ถึงเท่าไหร่คะเรียกว่าเด็ก
อ๋อถึงอายุของครัวตี้ขัวตีคิดว่าถ้าเด็ก
อายุก็ 1 ขวบใช่มั้ย 1 ขวบถึง 10  15 ไหม
ครับ
ใช่เขาเด็กน่าได้ครับหนึ่งถึงสิบห้าขวบ
จึง 19 ก็ยังเด็กนะ 19
อ๋อมันเป็นวัยรุ่นแล้วได้ครับก็เรียน
หนังสือที่โรงโรงเรียนทรายๆอย่างอะไรครับ
เค้กค่ะมีกี่อาทิตย์นะอาทิตย์อะไรนะคะ
ตำรวจครับ 2 อาชีพอะไรค่ะ 2 อาชีพเอ่อ 5
ๆแม่อ๋ออ๋อ
ครับอ่า
อาชีพตัดผมสั้นจัดผม
ฮะกลับเลิงค่าอาชีพครูใช่ครับอ่า
โอเคมีอาชีพที่ 6 ไหมคะถ้ามีอาชีพที่ 6
ครับอาชีพที่ 6 เป็นอาชีพอ่าอันนี้อะไร
ครับเห็นชอบเห็นแบบนี้ใส่เสื้อสีขาวใส่
หมวกสีขาวอ่ะอาชีพอะไรครับอาชีพผ้าครัว
เป็นพ่อครัว
ออกคืนทำอาหารใช่ไหมครับทำและ
วัว
ในโอ๊ยยแกแล้วคือมีอาหารใต้มีอาหารอยู่ใน
ครับ
เห็นพ่อครัวและ Q
Pro อตตี้ออฟดีคะพ่อครัวทำงานที่ไหนคะ
พ่อครัวทำงานในห้องครัวครับ
ในห้องครัวนี่มีพ่อครูที่ครัวพ่อครัวทำ
อาหารใหญ่ๆได้ไหมอ่าครูเอ๋อยากดูอาหาร
หรือหรืออยากดูพ่อครัวครับ
อยากดูอาหารคะ
โอเคนี่พ่อครัวกำลังทำอาหารหนัก Day
ในห้องครัวครับ
ทั้งหมดนะคะนักเรียนก็มี 6 อาชีพให้ครับ 6
นาทีสิบสำรวจนเอ่อตำรวจครับ
ได้ครับอ่าอาทิตย์ที่ 3 ชั้นตัดผมทราย
ช่างตัดผมหาที่ 4 นักดับเพลิง
ครับ
เพราะดูไอเขา
แค่ครัวว่าใส่ครับ
มีทั้งหมด 6 อาชีพทรายครับมี 6 นาที่โปร
อาที่ป้าจบแล้วใช่ไหมคะยังไม่จบครับ
เดี๋ยวเราจะอ่ะวันนี้ครัวตี้มีเกมให้นัก
เรียน
ด้วยอ่าเรียงอาชีพเหรอคะได้ครับเกมอาชีพ
เกมอาชีพเล่นยังไงคะอ้าเกมอาชีพๆเดี๋ยว
อ่าครัวตี้อ้าเปิดเกมนี้นะครับอ้า and
ที่นี่ก็จะมีโอมีสี่เหลี่ยมหาใช้ครับเป็น
สี่เหลี่ยมสีมี 4
สี่เหลี่ยมสีส้มอ่ะใช่ครับสี่เหลี่ยมสี
ส้มนะครับมีกี่รูปคะอ้ามีมีรู้สี่เหลี่ยม
อยู่ 6 รูปครับ 1  2  3  3  4  4  5  5  6
ห้ามี 6 รูปใช้ขาวรูปนะคะมีทั้งสี่
เหลี่ยม 6 รูปขับข้างในเป็นอะไรคะอ้าข้าง
ในครู Arty ใส่อ่าที่ทำงานของอ่าอาชีพที่
เราเรียนกันเมื่อกี้นี้อ่าใส่พี่ทำงานไว้
ไปครับก็คือกูอาร์จีจะให้ครูเอกคิดใช่ไหม
ๆให้คุยสมมติมีสติคลิ๊กที่ตำรวจ R  R ถ้า
ควรที่บอกว่าตำรวจครูเอกต้องเลือกว่า
ตำรวจทำงานที่ไหนน่ะผู้เห็นเลือกใหม่เลข
คิดว่าตำรวจทำงานที่สถานีตำรวจใช่ไหมครับ
สถานีตำรวจอยู่ที่ไหนว่างๆคุยต้อง
เลือกอ่ะอยู่อยู่ที่เลข 1 หรือเปล่าอยู่
ที่เลข 5 หรือเปล่าต้องเลือกให้เจอได้
ครับ
พี่แจ็คลิคภาพได้ครับได้ครับ
หาทำงานได้รวดยายทรายที่คุณเลือกได้กี่
ภาคคะ 1  2 อาร์ควงตีให้เลือกเกิด
2 ภาพ 2  3 แล้ว 2 ภาพนะครับนะ
ไม่รู้ตำรวจที่ไหนอยู่ไหนใช่มั้ยฮะโอเค
นักเรียนช่วยกูเอ๋จำณาช่วยกันทำเดี๋ยวควร
ที่จะเลือกอาชีพก่อนอาชีพที่ 1 อาทิตย์
ตื่นอาชีพอะไรครับหาทิปส์อะไรตำรวจถ้า
ตำรวจทำงานที่ที่ถานีตำรวจรวจโอเคเดี๋ยว
เราไปหาสถานีตำรวจอ่ะนะโอเคคู่เอกคิดคลิป
โป้เอไม่รู้ว่าคิดว่าอาจจะเลือกหมายเลข
อะไรครับเลขอะไรนักเรียนช่วยเหลือ 1
[เพลง]
2546 นายครับมี 6 คู่
การเลือกหมายเลข
หมายเลข 5 โอเคเดี๋ยวกลัวสิจะเปิดให้ได้
ชัดๆตำรวจภาษาไทยครับใช่ไหมครับหมายเลข 5
ก็ดีจะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะ
ช้า
ได้
สวัสดีเป็นก่อนไม่ใช่ไม่
ให้บอกไม่ใต้
ห้ามโจทก์ควรติใหม่ให้โจทก์เพราะควรตีให้
ให้เปิดซองครั้งเว้นไม่ต้องจดไม่ได้ต้อง
โจทย์หน้าไม่จนเปิดได้อีกเปิดได้อีกครั้ง
หนึ่งตำรวจใช้ครับ
ๆครั้งที่ 2 เลือดเบิร์ดมี 2 เบอร์เฮิร์ด
2 ใช่ไหมครับหาอ่าโอเค
ให้ไหมไอ้ไหมใช่ไหมอ่ะจะเปิดแล้วนะเปิด
เปิดครึ่ง
สองตาได้้
เอ๋เก่ง
[เพลง]
มีสถานีตำรวจเออได้มั้ย ani สถานีตำรวจ
ครับนักเรียนต้องเลือกกับเราเนาะ
อันนี้รูปที่ 1 นะคะหน้านี้แล้วนักเรียน
ต้องเลือกกับเราแล้วบอกว่าถูกรึหรืออิฐหา
แคร์แคร์อ่ะเอาครัวตี้เลือกหาอาชีพก่อน
เอาอาชีพอะไรดีอาชีพอะไรดีไปก่อนปิดอ่ะก็
ปิดฝา
ปิดค่ะโอเคเอาอาชีพ
อันนี้นี้อันนี้อันนี้เนี่ยอาชีพอะไรนะ
อ้าอันนี้อาชีพนักดับเพลิงอะนาทำงานที่
ไหนนะคะทำงานที่
สถานีดับเพลิง
หาหมายกับเริงเอกกับนักเรียนต้องครับ
ใช่ครับขาสถานี
อะไรอ่ะใช่ครับ 5 จะนะเฮิฟมามาแล้วครับ
หน้าหรือเลือก
สถานีดับเพลิงสถานีแบบเพื่อน
เอกจำได้เบิ่งนักเรียนเบอร์อะไรเบอร์อะไร
ดีครับพิมพ์ให้หน่อยพิมพ์พิมพ์ข้างล่าง
เบอร์อะไร
รู้เหมือนเลือกเบอร์
3 เบอร์ม 3 นะโอเคเดี๋ยวปวดที่จะเปิด
เบอร์ 3 นะครับเปิดเลยนะเปิดเลยนะเปิดค่ะ
เลยวันที่ 2
จะถ้าเกิดและเท่าเจ๊เอ้ไปเลยครับไม่ใช่ๆ
ไม่ใช่
ได้อีกหนึ่งใช่ได้อีก 1 ครั้งนะครับได้
อีก 1 นะคะคะเมื่อกี้อ่ะ
ขอเบอร์ 4 เบอร์ 4 ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะโอเค
สถานีดับเพลิง you เบอร์ 4 หรือไม่อยู่
อยู่ไหมห่าไม่รู้ไม่รู้อ่ะกวนตีจะเปิด
แล้วนะครับเปิดแล้ว
125 ได้
ครูเอ๋ทูกูอีกแล้วเดี๋ยวตัวตี้ใส่คะแนน
ให้ด้วยเลยนะเมื่อกี้ถูกแล้วเออ
เมื่อกี้สถานีตำรวจถูกไปแล้ว 1 คะแนนนะ
ครับนี้ปัญหานีดับเพลิงหน้าถูกแล้วได้ 2
คะแนนนะครับ
ครับพี่ค่ะคาบต่อไปเปิดหนึ่งก็ได้ให้ฮัน
นี่เฮๆกูเองเก่งแล้วเสียหายอ่ะก็เก่งแล้ว
เจ๊
เดี๋ยวกลัวตี้ปิดก่อนนะค่ะเดี๋ยวกลับไป
เลือกก่อนครับอาชีพต่อไปเอาอาชีพ
อาชีพนี้ครับหาชีพหมอนะคะอ๋ออ๋อหมอทำงาน
ที่ไหนครับหัวทำไงวง Klear บานหน้าที่รอง
พยาบาลโรงพยาบาล R5 ม้านักเรียนนักเรียน
กับครูเอ๋ช่วยกันช่วยกันหาหาหาโรงพยาบาล
อยู่แรกหมายเลขอะไรครับเค้กว่ะดีกูอีกคิด
ก่อนคลิปคิด
ๆกูเห็นเรื่องเลยอ้าเลือกหมายเลขอะไรครับ
หมายเทค 3 จะได้งับหมายเลข 3 จะเป็นทอง
โรงพยาบาลหรือเปล่าเดี๋ยวเป็นโรงพยาบาล
หรือเปล่าปาร์ตี้เปิดเลยเปิดแล้วเปิดเลย
หมายเลขต่างช้าดาววะว้าวโรงพยาบาลหมายเลข
3  5 ขูดต้องครับ
คุณหมอหมอหมอหมอทำงานที่โรงพยาบาลนะเคเอง
อะนี่โรงพยาบาลนะครับผมก็ให้คะแนนเพิ่ม
อีก 1 คะแนนน้าตอนนี้ได้ 3 คะแนนแล้วนะ
ครับอ่ะต่อไปครับต่อไปเดี๋ยวพี่ควรที่ปิด
ก่อนแล้วก็เอาอาชีพอะไรดีอ่า
อาชีพอาชีพอะไรดีอ้านี่ครับข้างตัดผมช่าง
ตัดผมมาช่างตัดผมทำงานที่ไหนครับร้านตัด
ผมถ้านี่ร้านตัดผมนักเรียนนักเรียนช่วย
ช่วยพี่เอ๋หาหาร้านตัดผมนะครับอ่ะว่าร้าน
ตัดผมอยู่อยู่หมายเลขอะไรครับ
อ่า
เปิดหนึ่งใช้นะอ้าเปิด 1 ครั้งครับดูอัด
ดี้อั D เบอร์ 5 เบอร์ 5 เบอร์ 5 นี้ได้
ขอเออฮ่าๆ
ผมค่ะให้หรือไม่ใช่ครับ
เฮ้ยใช่หรือไม่ใช่โอเคมามาดูกันหน้าแคบ
กว่าติดครับเปิดแล้วนะเปิดอีกแล้วนะมี
สอง
สามมาดา
โอเค
ติดแว่นขยายก็แค่นี่ร้านตัดผมเอาอ่าโอเค
โอเคๆเดี๋ยวคนตีใส่ไปแอบให้ก่อนพี่คะแนน
นะครับหมา
โอเคโอเค
อาชีพต่อไปอาชีพอะไรคะคิดอะไรดีต่อไปต้อง
เป็นอาชีพหาอาทิตย์นี้ครับ
แค่ครอบครัวๆเพราะกลัวทำงานที่ไหนครับที่
ห้องครัวหน้าพ่อครัวทำงานที่ห้องครัวน้าา
นักเรียนนักเรียนช่วยช่วยครูเอกคิดด้วย
ห้องครัวอยู่ที่ไหนล่ะสิโอเคเดี๋ยวกลัว
ตี้อากลับไปที่นะอ่าเกมให้เลือกไหมครับ
อ่าตอนนี้เหลืออยู่เหลือหมายเลขท่านใดที่
ยังไม่ได้เลือกครับหมายเลข 1 กับหมายเลข 6
อ่าโอเค
ควรติ๊กปวดอิอี้ช่วยช่วยให้ง่ายขึ้นกว่า
ตี้เปิดนิไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ใต้อันนี้ไม่ชา
ให้
ๆไม่ใช่แล้วก็ 6 จะให้
ได้เปิดแล้วอ่า
ครูเอกคิดนะ
เดาๆครับผมอ่ะหนึ่งหรือ
6-5 ก็เห็นเลือก
หมายเลข 6 เป็นห้องครัวเป็นห้องครัวหรือ
เปล่าอ่ะของครัวไหมปวดตี้เปิดแล้วนะเปิด
เปิด
เสจตื่นเต้นๆ
A5 ติ่ง
จะเปิดแล้วนะ
125 ได้
มีห้องครัว
ห้องครูให้ทิ้งจริงๆด้วย
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ดีใจอ่านักเรียนก็ดีใจเกย์แก่ๆ
เดี๋ยวหัวตี้ให้อีก 1 คะแนนเป็น 5 คะแนน
และตอนนี้คะแนน 5
เขาไปอาชีพสุดท้ายครับอาชีพครู
ครูทำงานที่ไหนครับ
โรงเรียนค่ะค่ะครูทำงานที่โรงเรียนนะครับ
อ่ะโอเคอ้อควรตีไม่ได้ปิดที่นี้ทีนี้ไม่
ต้องเลือกน่ะใช่ไหม
มาดูเรื่องแหละเบอร์นึงแล้วถูกแน่นอน
เบอร์ 1 แหวนรองเรียนโอเคลงกันครับ KR ก็
ได้แขนทั้งหมด 6 คะแนนคุณค่าครับ
นักเรียนได้กี่คะแนนค่ะอายนักเรียนได้กี่
คะแนนนักเรียนได้เท่ากับเท่ากับครู a ไหม
เข้ากันมั้ยอ่าโอเคได้ 6 คะแนนโอเค
คะแนนถ้าทั้งหมดนะคะมีอาชีพอะไรบ้างคะ 5
มีอาชีพอะไรบ้างใช่ไหมครับเดี๋ยวนะกลัว
ติ๊บเปิดอาชีพที่ 1 ครับอาชีพ
ตำรวจไหมครับห่า
r-moral.net
ทีบที่ 4 อาอ้านะดับเลิงแย่หน้าครูไหม
ครับ 6 อาชีพที่ 6 พ่อครัว
เวลาหรือยังคะหมดเวลาแล้วครับเวลาแล้ว
ถ่ายครับ R
crew แฮปปี้กับผู้ S ต้องครับ 5 ลาไป
ก่อนครับแถวกลับมาพบกันใหม่ที่ช่อง
คอมเพลนสเบอร์ไทยคราวหน้าเราหน้า 5 วัน
นี้ครัวตี้สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋อ่ะ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายน